did somebody over here order some cup
cakes if you've been on tick tock at all
in the last few months you may have come
across these leggings that make your
butt
look bodacious a couple of my co-workers
actually tested these a little while ago
but
i've never seen men try them out so
today myself and a couple other guys are
going to be trying out these leggings to
see whether they do wonders
for our asses everybody and they moms
been wearing and trying these on and i
can see why from like the tick tock
videos and the pictures
that i've seen for research these
leggings really do
shape the butt look like a normal pair
of pants
just with added texture what i imagine a
superhero costume would feel like
i didn't know that it like kind of like
scrunches like this in the butt and i
think this is what gives it like
that shape you know it's kind of like a
pre-made veggie
generally i'm actually pretty okay with
my butt it's it's got some shape to it
if i do some posing
it's like oh look at that look at that
that's a butt
it's not the most stand out but in the
world but you know it's a butt what can
you do i don't have the hugest butt
but i think that you know i mean i think
i have a nice curve
but it looked more like a d than a
period
i currently don't think there's anything
wrong with my butt
it looks looks fine to me the only
problem
i would say is that there is a crack
right down the middle i really hope that
these legends come through because i've
been wanting
that dump truck for a while now let's
get these on and see if i can get a
magical tick tock but
oh um
damn look at that oh my god oh
yes oh look at it
look at that it's not a dump truck just
yet
but maybe a dump sedan you know honestly
i feel like the butt's the same
still kind of flat they are very
comfortable though
i don't like the feeling in the front
because it was clearly not designed with
certain body parts
in mind but damn like i like these for
me
as far as my booty goes though oh you
can see her
doesn't look too bad boom screenshot
this i know you want to
[Music]
i'm gonna try the bend and snap
not as great as l woods i i know it's
just the angle
but holy god i look like captain america
whoever made this thing can genius
this really does accentuate
things how do models do it there's like
one leg forward
is it the other leg forward no it's got
to be this leg forward so that they can
twist it there we go that's the one
these are something i would
wear to bed so something i would wear on
a work from home day
not something i think i would wear to
break a sweat
i'm not opposed to wearing these to like
work out or do yoga or something
or honestly just to like lounge around
these are these are soft they're comfy
and any other people around get a
special treat of a view
hey
what'd you say the fit feels really nice
this makes me feel really good about my
legs
i don't necessarily think i have the
biggest ass
but the the clothing kind of accentuates
it even though i don't necessarily like
have a
donka dunk men don't necessarily like
show off their curves and things like
that regularly so it's nice to you know
um put some exclamation points on my
name you know i got a booty too
and i just feel like we need to show
some more love in the booty community
but regardless of what your booty
capacity is uh get you some leggings and
feel good about yourself
overall if you're a guy and you wanna
up your butt your butt game these aren't
a terrible option
it just it's very interesting really
really interesting how fashion really
does
frame our bodies to what we want people
to perceive
that does look pretty good i'm gonna
wear these for the rest of the day
why not right as always links to check
these out will be in the description
below
thank you so much for watching and um
i'm gonna go feel sexy for the rest of
the day
you